aujourd'hui grand ménage de printemps
avec la dernière touche au sens propre
et figuré dans cette étrange quand
j'appuie sur la valve la bombe refroidi
pour comprendre on va dire une petite
expérience quand je compris mme de l'air
ça chauffe elle les molécules qui
composent l'air se rapproche et agitent
cette activité génère de l'énergie sous
forme de chaleur quand j'appuie sur la
malle
le phénomène inverse se produit l'air à
l'intérieur de la bombe est comprimé au
moment où j'appuie sur la balle
c'est comme si j'ouvrais une porte le
gaz à l'intérieur se détend pour
s'écarter les unes des autres
les molécules qui composent l'air puisse
de l'énergie dans leur environnement
dans le fluide à l'intérieur de la bombe
ce qui a pour effet de refroidir le
contenu et le contenant et cette capsule
de les confiner
si vous avez aimé cette capsule
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
vous pouvez aussi voir ou revoir celle
des jours précédents en cliquant sur le
côté gauche
j'en réalise une nouvelle par jour alors
pour éviter d'en louper lien
abonnez-vous et est active et la petite
cloche à liens de vin et n'oublie pas
nous sommes confinés les en restant lien